ALEX DANILO: Hi.
I'm Alex Danilo from the
Google Developer Platform team.
As a developer, I want
more people to use my apps,
and to spend more
time using them,
so I get more bang for my buck,
especially if it means more
in-app purchases, or
ad viewing time that
turns into real
money in my pocket.
The average TV viewer spends
up to three hours a day
in front of their TV set.
If only there was a way to get
my apps onto that big screen
to take advantage of all
that time, I could be rich.
Well, there is a way.
It's called Google Cast.
Google cast is a technology
that lets you, as a developer,
extend your existing app onto
the big screen in people's
living room.
It's so simple easy to
add casting capability
to your apps, that
soon enough, you'll
be reeling in more and more
users to enjoy your creations.
And I'm going to take
you through a quick tour
of how easy it is to do so.
Google Cast is a way to connect
different devices and screens
together.
You can think of it as a way to
extend your app's functionality
out from where you
ship your app today,
onto another big screen that
lots of people can share.
The app you already have is the
place where the magic starts.
We call that the sender.
Sender apps can be on a
phone, both iOS or Android,
or a tablet, or even a laptop
running a web application.
Senders start the action,
and they send or cast stuff
from the app onto
the big screen.
When you cast something
from your app-- the sender--
it needs to get
caught by something.
That's what the receiver is for.
Google Cast runs on receiving
devices, like the Chrome Cast.
At the start casting,
a small application
we call the receiver
gets downloaded
onto the receiving device.
Your sender application controls
which receiver application
gets loaded onto
the cast device.
The cast-enabled sender,
like your existing app,
just needs to
integrate the cast SDK
to enable discovery
of existing cast
devices on the local network.
Once it finds devices
nearby, the Google Cast icon
becomes visible to
users within your app.
Clicking on that icon turns the
sender into a remote control,
and we have a ton
of UI guidelines
about how to make
everything that
follows a magical and
intuitive experience.
Things like selecting
your cast device,
pausing and scrubbing, or just
making it look really nice.
So with the small amount of
code inside your existing
application, you can trigger
a receiver application
on a cast-enabled device to
extend the reach of your app
onto the big screen
to let lots of people
enjoy the capabilities
you have to offer.
When you kick off a receiver
application from your app,
the cast device just
pulls that in from the URL
hosted on a server somewhere.
Pretty simple, really.
But that's where
the magic happens.
Since the cast device
runs by itself,
you can tell it to load
things like media streams,
which load directly from the
cloud, onto the cast device,
and your sender app
does no work at all,
apart from setting it all up.
You can also send
messages from your app
to the receiver application,
so you can control things
like playing, and pausing,
and volume, et cetera.
The receiver application itself,
which shows your content,
is built with web
technology, and is in fact
an HTML5 application, written
in HTML5, CSS, and JavaScript,
which makes it super
simple to develop.
We've also provided a bunch
of sample receiver apps,
so you can get
started without having
to write any
receiver code at all.
What you make the receiver
do is totally up to you.
You can send pictures
across, make it
a game score display,
or almost anything
that's up to your imagination.
Getting started
couldn't be easier.
If you develop Android,
iOS, or even web apps,
we've got you all covered
with an SDK for each platform.
We have full source
code examples
of a bunch of different
sender applications,
with all sorts of
functionality that you
can take a look at,
cut and paste code out
of, and integrate into your
existing applications in almost
no time.
We also have a bunch of
different receiver applications
that can run on your cast
device right out of box.
We also have an example of a
fully customizable receiver
application.
It delves into more complex
receiver capabilities,
such as licensed content
serving, different video
formats, adaptive streaming,
and all that other tricky stuff.
To get started, you should jump
onto our developer console,
and register as a
developer, so that you
can begin making your
app cast enabled.
So get to it.
Cast enable your app now,
and watch the magic happen
as your app becomes
the main focus
in living rooms everywhere.